il s'est passé un truc de fou hier qui
m'a traumatisé toute la nuit a lancé une
jeune femme de 19 ans estelle a failli
mourir parce qu'elle s'est teint les
cheveux une substance très allergène en
fait est présente dans pratiquement
toutes les colorations
voilà où le savez il y en a plein qui
ont dû faire des décolorations ici et la
jeune femme a décidé de lancer une
alerte à tous ceux qui utilisent ces
produits vous a préparé un récap de
cette histoire me regarder c'est
complètement ouf
et ça fait vraiment flipper et on
embrasse forestel on espère voilà
qu'elle qu'elle valait mieux et c'est
vrai que c'est un traumatisme pour l on
regarde c'est un fait divers qui fait le
tour d'internet depuis 48 heures et qui
alertent sur les dangers de la
coloration l'histoire d'une jeune
étudiante blonde de 19 ans qui voulait
changer de tête en se teignant en brune
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'elle a complètement changé de tête
pressée de se teindre les cheveux la
jeune femme n'a pas pris le temps de
tester d'abord sur une petite parcelle
de sa peau la coloration pendant 48
heures comme ses conseillers pour voir
si elle était ou non allergiques et le
résultat est à peine croyable en
quelques heures son cuir chevelu s'est
mis à la démangeait et le lendemain au
réveil c'est le drame off ça commence
par des démangeaisons ensuite en arrière
de la tête
faysal boucle ça a gonflé d'un manu gel
frank avait vraiment doubler ce volume
est temps que l'événement
la jeune femme a tout simplement failli
mourir pour une coloration se dit pas
quand nous aurons coloration sa gorge
gonflé l'empêché de respirer
correctement mais prise en charge à
temps aux urgences elle est aujourd'hui
saine et sauve en cause la
paraphenylènediamine un produit présent
dans la majorité des teintures du marché
bref la prochaine fois que vous faites
une couleur penser à tester le produit
48 heures avant alors elle aurait pu
vraiment y passer et effectivement ce
qui a été dit dans le sujet est vrai
c'est à dire qu'elle a testé mais
simplement une petite heure et donc elle
n'a pas eu le temps
la teinture de éventuellement faire
révéler tous toutes les molécules
allergènes et en fait il faut vraiment
testé pendant 48 heures pour être
certain de ce que vous ne réagissez pas
cette cette molécule produits pour
cheveux à moi j'ai failli devenir
chauffeur avec un du frison qui m'a dit
exactement le même truc gonfler les yeux
mais dès le salon cause des prisons et
catherine lara a raconté qu'avec un
shampoing elle était sortie chauffe non
un shampoing elle m'a enlevé comme un
aveu
moi pareil
[Musique]
à temps
je suis sans voix est-ce que vous pouvez
me permettre de lancer un cri d'alarmé
c'est vrai à propos du reportage là qui
m'a bouleversé et et je lance un appel à
toutes les jeunes filles notamment noirs
ou métis qui veulent aussi se blanchir
la peau
c'est la même chose j'ai vu récemment de
nombreuses brûlures qui aurait pu être
très très grave
heureusement ça a été pris en charge à
temps dans les cas que j'ai vu mais ça
peut être extrêmement dangereux
j'allais dire ne le fait pas mais en
tout cas si vous le faites il faut voir
un médecin avant il faut faire attention
voir ce qu'il ya dans les produits y en
a de plus en plus c'est une mode et
c'est extrêmement dangereux
ça me permet de le souligner fait
attention merci gilles verlant merci
thierry braillard vous voulez on voulait
parler de ça absolument et c'est vrai
que fait attention ça ça me ça ça m'a
rendu ou ce mois j'ai fait tellement de
coloration avec les poulets paris a
policy j'ai pensé à tout-va oui